Donald Trump is
under multiple criminal inquiries,
but there are signs
he may face charges
in the first of those this week.
For more,
I want to talk to the reporter
who perhaps knows
Trump, the best
senior political correspondent
for The New York Times, Maggie Haberman,
who has been awarded a Pulitzer Prize
for her coverage of the former
president Maggie.
Behind the scenes,
what can you tell us about
how Trump is handling this situation?
Look, Jake,
he's very anxious
about the prospect of being indicted
for a couple of reasons.
Yes. Two things can be true at once.
He is aware
that there are reasons to believe
this could help him politically.
We have heard a lot about this
this morning already,
but he does not want to face
getting arrested,
which is what happens
when you get indicted.
You get fingerprinted you get brought in.
You have to ask for bail.
None of that is something
that he is excited about.
So he and his folks,
his his political folks
are preparing
for a huge blitz politically
to push back on the Manhattan
district attorney.
You saw that start yesterday,
although I don't think that his true
social post yesterday
morning calling for protests was part of
part of a grand plan.
He did it
and a bunch of his aides
were surprised by it.
But I do think that that is separate
from what you're going to see
legally and.
Well,
I know that his folks are suggesting
this is a weak case.
They don't actually know
what the evidence is.
What it is is trivial compared
to the other inquiries.
That doesn't mean
there won't be a conviction
and they have to be mindful of that.
Trump called in his supporters,
as you noted,
to protest and, quote,
take our nation back
on that truth social post.
Obviously, the last time
Donald Trump
called for his supporters to rally,
it resulted in an insurrection
at the Capitol.
Does he have any concern about violence?
No.
This is not something that,
you know,
he expresses enormous concern
about to anyone.
That doesn't
mean people around him are not concerned
about what he's saying about protest.
And they are because as you know well,
he is still under investigation.
One of these inquiries
by the Justice Department
is about the events
leading up to January 6th and his efforts
to stay in power.
And there have been
lots of people, hundreds
arrested in connection
with that attack on the Capitol.
So this is not something he voices
a whole lot of concern about,
but it is absolutely something folks in
his world
are mindful of that
this is going to keep coming up,
especially as he pushes this.
And this is having an effect
of rallying Republicans around him.
I mean, you have Speaker McCarthy
calling it an outrageous abuse of power.
That that's not that surprising.
He's he's
always been very supportive
of Donald Trump,
but even would be rival
Mike Pence says he's taken aback
and he says
it reeks of political prosecution.
We heard Governor Sununu today
suggesting that he didn't think this was.
This rose
to the magnitude
of of such an unprecedented action.
We still have not heard, however,
from Nikki Haley or from Ron DeSantis.
What do you think
is the political calculus there?
I think that Ron DeSantis is going to try
to avoid weighing in on this
as long as possible,
and he will
then decide
whether as long as possible has been met.
You saw yesterday on Twitter
one of Trump's advisers, Jason Miller,
highlighting that DeSantis has not said
anything yet.
DeSantis is obviously
the governor of the state
where Trump lives.
And, you know, should Trump decide
he's not going to surrender?
Should that not happen? Peacefully?
If he is indicted
and expected to be charged,
then DeSantis
would have to make some decisions.
And so this gets very complicated.
Trump's own
folks are aware
and this came up last week
repeatedly as I was reporting this out.
They believed that
if Trump was to be charged,
this could put his rivals in a bind,
especially Ron DeSantis,
because they are going to be called upon
to speak out against it.
And as you just noted,
the pressure is already building.
So Trump says he's committed
to staying in the 20, 24 race,
even if he is indicted
That sounds
completely characteristic,
but is it realistic?
I don't think it's unrealistic,
depending on what else happens, Jake.
If it is just this case,
then I think
it isn't unrealistic that he stays in,
although we have no idea
exactly when a trial would be.
Would it even be this year?
Would it stretch into next year?
The point
I think, is that we are talking about
potentially multiple indictments.
We are talking about an indictment
in Georgia
possibly happening in the coming months.
We are talking about
indictment, indictments
from the federal government
happening in the coming months.
That becomes a lot of freight to carry
in a presidential race.
And you can start to see a world
where Republicans might say
on this one case in Manhattan,
we feel it's you know, it's trivial.
But these other cases,
this drip, drip, it's just constant drama
and let's move on. We'll see.